in July former vice president Mike Pence
was campaigning in Iowa where questions
quickly turned to Donald Trump and
January 6th if it wasn't for your vote
we would not have Joe Biden in the white
house right I know by God's grace I did
exactly what the Constitution of the
United States required of me that day
I kept my oath
Mike Pence and Donald Trump were
completely an odd couple that worked
very well together you know I love my
great don't we
then came you know January 6th and it
all all crumbled
much of Pence's testimony and
contemporaneous notes are at the heart
of the Justice Department's case against
Donald Trump and his alleged crimes
committed in a desperate bid to stay in
power he was not only my president he
was my friend that tragic day in January
will
will always be a day of great sadness
for me here's what the latest indictment
against Trump tells us about how that
relationship unfolded after the 2020
election and what it could mean for the
next one
Trump chose Pence as his running mate
largely to shore up more traditional
Republican voters
pulled in a lot of people that were
skeptical of trump that felt more at
ease having Mike Pence at his side Pence
certainly deserves some credit for for
Trump uh winning the presidency and
during the administration they found
that they worked pretty well together a
lot of people were sort of still kind of
scratching their heads how do these two
guys get together
um and and Pence stood by Trump
throughout you know numerous
controversies when Trump was President
they got along and by all accounts up
until you know leading up to you know
Trump losing the election once Joe Biden
was projected to win the election the
justice department says Trump began a
campaign based on false claims to change
as many of these states as possible from
Biden wins to Trump wins Trump has
denied wrongdoing and has accused
prosecutors of pursuing him for
political reasons
if you say something about an election
they want to put you in jail for the
rest of your life it's a disgrace here's
what the indictment says happened once
the efforts Within the states failed the
focus turned to Pence who as vice
president was tasked with certifying the
votes from the electors of the Electoral
College and therefore the election on
December 23rd Trump's plan became for
the vice president to announce that
because of the ongoing disputes in the
seven states there are no electors that
can be deemed validly appointed and he
would gavel in Trump as re-elected
two days later Trump brought it up to
pence in a phone call but Pence pushed
back saying you know I don't think that
I have the authority to change the
outcome
a few days later when Trump brought it
up again Pence pushed back again saying
he thought it was improper Trump told
him you're too honest
Pence is a you know a very traditional
Republican lot of adherence to
constitutional values that's just kind
of in his DNA I'm sure it was a very
tough you know thing for him to do I
mean he was under just tremendous
pressure but I don't think it's that
surprising that he took that stance as
hard as it might have been
indictment says Trump pressured Pence
several more times and Pence continued
to say he couldn't overturn the election
and I hope Mike hence comes through for
us I have to tell you of course if he
doesn't come through I won't like him
quite as much
in a final meeting on January 5th Trump
grew frustrated and told Pence that he
would have to publicly criticize him
which made Pence's Chief of Staff
concern for his safety and he alerted
the Secret Service that night Trump
continued the pressure tweeting if Pence
comes through for us we will win the
presidency there was a lot of
anticipation in how Pence would act on
the morning of January 6 the indictment
alleges an unnamed agent for Trump
contacted a U.S senator to ask him to
hand deliver documents to Pence
prosecutors allege those documents were
fraudulent certificates signed by
fraudulent electors in Michigan and
Wisconsin when a pence staff member was
contacted about the documents staffer
rejected them later that morning after a
call with Pence Trump delivered a speech
where he called him out claiming he
could change the election outcome
and I hope Mike is going to do the right
thing I hope so
I hope so because if Mike Pence does the
right thing we win the election before
you know Pence went up there to to do
his duty he released this statement
laying out why he could not upset the
certification of the election and it set
up this you know profound moment of
tension in which the vice president was
going to go and defy the wishes of of
the president
before Trump finished his speech the
indictment says a crowd began to gather
at the Capitol
back at the White House Trump tweeted
that Pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done
one minute after Trump's tweet the
Secret Service evacuated Pence to a
secure location the attack on the
capitol delayed the certification for
approximately six hours it wasn't until
the early hours of January 7th that
Pence announced the certified results of
the 2020 election in favor of Biden the
chair declares The Joint session
dissolved
the political Fallout for Pence was
almost immediate not just a threat to
him you know physically as we saw him
get yanked out of the capital but
immediately saw Trump trump supporters
turn on him now the two are both running
for president in 2024. Pence definitely
is
got an odd line to walk because he's at
once criticizing
Trump Anyone who puts themselves over
the Constitution should never be
president of the United States
and anyone who asks someone else to put
them over the Constitution should never
be president of the United States again
but also you know saying how proud he
was to be at his side for so long I'm
incredibly proud of the record of the
Trump Pence Administration Trump is the
clear front-runner where Pence is
hovering around five percent in National
polls Trump is so far ahead that he
doesn't give too much notice to Pence
but when when Pence speaks out Trump is
often will will come back at him after
Trump's indictment was announced Pence
criticized Trump's actions after the
election sadly the president was
surrounded by a group of crackpot
lawyers that kept telling him what his
itching ears wanted to hear Trump
responded I feel badly for Mike Pence
who is attracting no crowds enthusiasm
or loyalty he didn't fight against
election fraud he's going to get a lot
of heat from from from voters who think
that he costs Trump another term for the
time being I think January 6 kind of
blaunted any kind of future political
aspirations for Pence I said before I
said when I announced president Trump
was wrong
about my authority that day and he's
still wrong
I believe it with all my heart